game six of the nationally championship
series the dodgers a chance to force
game seven and the focus is on young
walker bueller this pro season does not
have a decision good numbers good era
next up is marcel ozuna
there's a fly ball into right and that
could not have gone
better for bueller or the dodgers
seven pitches three outs max friedel try
to do the same against the dodgers one
walk nine strikeouts so far in the
postseason this year here comes the
unconscious
corey seeger eight for 20 in the nlcs
with four home runs and 10 rbis right in
the middle of it and here's one into
right
down the line it is gone seekers got
another
and the dodgers jump on top in game six
home run number five for corey seeger of
this
lcs oh that could have very well been a
hit or sitting on the breaking ball joe
he threw a lot of breaking balls the
first two at bat struck him out twice 73
miles an hour hit it almost as high as
the roof 15.
rbi now one into left center field back
is pache off the battle turner
it's gone
back to back
two nothing dodgers here in the first
inning seeger now turner what a start
not just his first home run
of this lcs but his first rbi and
another one just outside the glove
of pogba this this is you're not going
to see two closer opportunities to rob a
home run only one out bellinger with
just three hits in this series
that's another base hit
and to score is muncie stopping at
second is smith and the wheel keeps on
turning for la of three to nothing as
bellinger drives in his fourth of the
series
lead man is darno at second
there's a base hit in the left
darno had the hole to make sure that got
by seeger
and now a bad throw to the plate but
nobody can advance the bases are loaded
three straight singles here in the
second the braves making noise down
three nothing braves have the bases
loaded and nobody out yeah and you see
momentum it goes from one side to the
other and already in this game it is
maybe looking like a tennis match what
riley has to do is put it play it
somewhere
just found it
99 and he just reared back and those
last two pitches riley couldn't catch up
this will be a back breaker inning for
the atlanta braves if they don't punch a
run across up to marcakus
strikes out looking
this
is what an ace looks like after giving
up three straight singles locker bueller
trying to help the dodgers force a game
seven could strike out the side against
the bottom three in the lineup
here's a ground ball left side seeger
with a backhand
inning is over what a job by bueller
loads of bases with nobody out and then
gets out of the mess austin barnes
number nine hit her first up
there's a strikeout to start the inning
in the first strike out of the game for
freed bats on with a single with one out
corey seeger in this series is just
taking a crack at it
good pitch here by free tied him up down
and in well done by the young
left-hander two out that was one of the
first fastballs that really exploded and
took off inside towards corey seeger now
it's riley again two on and one out here
in the fourth oh two
that is smashed into center field but
right at bellinger what a bad break for
riley he crunched it
but out number two and the runners able
to get back to first and second it's up
to marcakus euler brings it and a ground
ball back to the right hander stabs it
flips it gang over
and now the braves have left five
one for six with runners in scoring
position in this game and down by three
runners are at the corners with two down
leaves the inning up to justin turner
dodgers looking to add on to the lead
and a ground ball left side for riley
loves it
throws it good work by freed
gets around to hitting the walk dodgers
now have left six
freeman is a board with a two out single
to right
here's a high fly ball into right back
as bets on the move on the track he's
got it
to end the inning what a catch by mookie
betts
spooky bench has done it again
oh man
time perfectly
goes up and right at the yellow line at
the top of the wall makes the catch and
boy did mookie bets do a dance after he
made the catch you want to know about
excitement
this this is like robbing a home run
on a shorter fence and he got way up
runner third two out see if the braves
can turn that into a run the stolen base
the throwing error and now
riley strikes out the ball is picked up
by the catcher barnes who flips it to
muncie to record the strikeout odd top
of the sixth inning for the braves less
than 90 pitches and he gives way to
blake trinin under a third one out and a
fly ball into right field that ball is
down and into the corner in the score is
marcakis digging for second and holding
with an rbi double lacuna and it's a
three to one game and he got a sinker
right there that he was able to place
down the right field lineup here's muncy
another 3-2 pitch muncie strikes out and
with will smith coming up here comes
brian snicker after the fifth strikeout
of the night by freed aaron o'day
here's a smash what a pick by swanson on
the short hop to rob will smith and now
the infield swings around the other way
for the right-handed hitting dansby
swanson here it comes and a high fly
ball into right easy for bets and how
about the job done
by pedro baez on the heels of the work
by blake trynan so jansen is in to close
it austin reilly first up against kenley
janssen and a line drive into left field
is caught
on a diving rolling catch by jack
peterson just into the game it will be
pablo sandoval
o2 pitch
fly ball into left should do it and the
dodgers sports game seven as jansen has
an uneventful one two three ninth inning
to save it what a job by number 74.